[Musique]
je veux un avocat cette époque est
révolue
[Applaudissements]
petit frère frère faire tu dois choisir
ton qu'encore
bonjour gabriel je veux un avocat je
sais aussi bien moi que c'était pâques
est révolu tu as le choix travailler
pour moi ou finir comme ton père on n'a
pas beaucoup de temps
avant le premier contact de novation
entre nous nous avions besoin que les
législateurs nous montre la voie il nous
protège de l'anarchie
et à nos amis sous terre qu'ils font
tout notre soutien
l'harmonie la paix mensonges elles vont
tout nous prendre tu veux que je fasse
quoi ton cou riposte on a une chance
l'inscription se prépare sous le nom
d'opération félix
qui communique sur les réseaux il
prévoit un truc énorme équipe entre
l'action ce soir vous êtes prêts vous
laissez pas prendre vivant
bonjour gabriel tu as une mission à
accomplir
j'ai un plan que j'ai confiance en toi
une simple étincelle
à déclencher une guerre
je veux bien prendre le risque
pour que les choses reviennent comme
avant
comme je le disais j'étais parti est
révolu
ça
ah ah